part of the the bootcamp is sort of a
mini course organized by a new knowledge
and give the first part of it and I just
wanted to you know they're a bunch of
organizers listed for the workshop that
John Holman was there but there is
gentleman did a lot of the
organizational work so he should
and I yeah so we're really very lucky
and happy to have trekked up thanks for
inviting me so I guess I will you're
some kind of a tutorial or large-scale
differentially private machine learning
I will not assume anything other than
what could be already said so I'll start
with the basics we'll go over the
definition some simple mechanisms so I
guess for the first two hours I'll talk
about the about differentially private
learning in the central model where you
have a trusted curator who collects the
data set and does learning on top of
that in the third hour Illya will talk
about learning in the local model where
we do not assume across calculator and I
believe the current plan which isn't
fully solidified yet is to have chief
Chen another colleague of mine give a
demo of the differentially private
machine learning library that we built
at Google and open sourced and if any of
you want to try that library out we'll
have a demo of that too to see how it
actually works in practice
so I'll start with the basics of
potentially price of differential
privacy will then apply them to some
machine learning tasks including I guess
in the second lecture kind of training
large machine learning models and then
just so not everyone out just so some of
the people are already familiar with
this works so just to give them
something I'll talk about some recent
results which are applicable to not just
two differentially private machine
learning but I think do I think more are
more interesting from just two
differentially private algorithm or
differentially private meta algorithms
design at larger at large job I'll try
to go slowly if there are any questions
do stop me and hopefully everything
should be should be relatively simple
okay so let's start again with the
different definition of differential
privacy we say a mechanism M which will
map data set so a data set is is indeed
to the end there and people in the data
set each of them contributes an element
of D the mechanism allowed put something
from some abstract range space R we will
n R can change between different
mechanisms of course we'll say this this
mechanism satisfies epsilon Delta
differential privacy if for any
measurable subset of the range and any
pair of neighboring data sets D and E
prime it is the case that the
probability of this event s under D is
within an e to the epsilon
multiplicative factor of the probability
of that event under D prime plus an
additive Delta
so think of e to the epsilon where
epsilon is small this is like one plus
epsilon so these treatments are
relatively close even if epsilon is a
small constant this is still giving you
some guarantees on how large the ratio
of these two events can be we'll think
of neighbors as two data sets that
differ in the contribution of one person
for the most part we will imagine each
person contributing one row to the data
set but there's nothing in the
definition that requires that to be the
case and in fact some of the work we all
talk about will have the property that
one person contributes some large chunk
of data will still have we'll have to
redefine the nation notion of
neighborhood in that case and still get
privacy
okay so I guess yes I'll maybe ate a
little bit from the usual treatment of
differential privacy for reasons that
will become clear so a central concept
in this talk will be this notion of the
privacy lost random very so what is a
privacy loss privacy lost random
variable is a lot of notation so let's
go over it slowly so first consider the
following function Z which takes an
outcome so oh is an outcome in the range
space of the algorithms is the possible
answer given by the mechanism and let me
look at the probability that M outputs
this value on D divide that by the
probability of the same event same
outcome on D Prime and look at the log
of this ratio this is the real number
this is a ratio of probabilities so it's
obviously positive
so taking blocks is valid but this can
be positive or negative this ratio is
roughly if I was confused as an observer
if I had first if I was trying to
determine whether the actual data set is
D or D prime this ratio is how much do
my how much is my posterior different
from my prior on these two events given
the outcome oh so I come in with some
beliefs I think maybe it's equal lots
that Kobe is a GCS plus or not then I
see the outcome of the mechanism and
based on the outcome my my odds between
these two events change this ratio is
exactly capturing how much had those
odds changed
this definition kind of makes sense when
the outputs paid when the mechanism is
Banaras discreet when it's continuous we
look at the ratio of densities at some
point so that defines a function Z note
that the Z are the function of M D and D
prime though we will omit these when
convenient the Z Maps any output to a
real number the privacy loss random
variable is defined as follows I sample
an outcome from M on D and then compute
this scalar function Z on that outcome
I'm running the mechanism on the looking
at the outcome and I'm asking what is
the value of this privacy loss function
on that outcome this is a random
variable because M is a random variable
and this is the random variable that
will be the will be to a large extent
very important in the stock
yeah so this function depends on D D
Prime I'm a little confused I'm on
repairs so D and D prime are two
neighboring data sets so I'm fixing to
neighboring data sets fixing the
mechanism and looking at this function
this random variable Z so to be precise
this Z is a function of M D and D Prime
there are three parameters associated
with this definition I'll omit them when
convenient but for the whole talk let's
we will fix the D Prime and they are in
the context of memory so it could for
example be the model output by the
mechanism or the parameters of the model
so the in the machine learning context
the mechanism will take a data set the
training data set and output a machine
learning model it could be a deep model
yeah
r is the set of all possible parameters
always one specifically set o is one
specific setting of parameters
any more questions neighboring is what
we talked about in last night
neighboring datasets are two datasets
that differ in the contribution of one
person in most cases if every person
contributes one row to the dataset D and
E Prime differ in one row so in the
prime Kobey's data has been did release
from the data set leave has copies data
okay so with that in mind let's go back
to the definition of differential
privacy so even before this pure
differential privacy or epsilon0
differential privacy says that for every
D and every D Prime that's the neighbor
of T the privacy loss random variable is
always bounded by Epsilon
so the privacy lost randomvariable was
this log of this ratio pure differential
privacy says that this is at most e to
the epsilon times this we hit it with a
log we get something that's always
bounded by absolute so differential
privacy fundamentally is talking about
this random variable your differential
privacy says that this random variable
is always bounded by epsilon and epsilon
Delta differential privacy talks about
the tails of this random variable it
says that the probability that this
random variable is bounded is exceeds
epsilon is at most Delta
so this is not obvious so let's give a
proof okay so
good so let's call be the set of all
outcomes where this random variable is
larger than absolute so now we'll write
probability that MD is in s can be
broken up into the contribution coming
from V complement and the contribution
coming from B the second part we will
just upper bound by the total
probability mass of B which by
assumption is that most Delta when we
are in B complement the privacy loss
random variable is bounded by Epsilon
which means that the ratio of
probability of MD being a certain
outcome is at most e to the epsilon
times the probability of MD prime being
that same outcome so if I kind of write
this as an integral over over the
probability space term by term the
probabilities change by at most e to the
epsilon so I get this bound
good so what we have said so far is that
differential privacy is talking about
controlling the tails of this random
variable
okay so keep that in mind now let's talk
about a real about an actual
differentially private mechanism so here
is the simplest or one of the simplest
differentially private mechanisms which
is known as the Gaussian mechanism this
is a mechanism for releasing an
approximation to a function Q on the
data set which is just the sum of Q
applied to individual elements of the
data set for some Q between 0 and that
Maps every data set to be something real
number between 0 and 1 think of Q as a
predicate it counts how many people
satisfy a certain property the Q of a
certain person is 1 if they satisfy the
property 0 if they don't Q of D then
computes the total number of people in
the data set satisfying this property
the Gaussian mechanism says compute Q on
the real data set and then add noise
proportional from a Gaussian
distribution with variance Sigma squared
so this is what the distribution of this
mechanism looks like
so here's the theorem will prove if I
set Sigma appropriately to be something
like square root log 1 over Delta
divided by Epsilon under some mild
technical conditions this mechanism is
epsilon delta differentially primate
let's prove this so first let's go back
to our privacy loss random variable the
privacy loss random variable at some
point X X is a real number now okay so
let's just shift things around let's
without loss of generality assume that Q
of D is 0 and Q of B prime is minus 1
this is just shifting this mechanism is
kind of translation invariant so this is
not this is without loss of generality
so what's the probability density at a
point X when I sample from M of D it's
just e to the minus x squared over 2
Sigma squared divided by some
normalizing constant when I change the
mean of the Gaussian to from X to from 0
to minus 1 the density at X goes down to
something like e to the minus X plus 1
squared over 2 Sigma squared
simple algebra this is just X plus one
squared minus x squared over 2 Sigma
squared which is 2x plus 1 over 2 Sigma
squared so we've computed the privacy
loss function for this
recall that we wanted to bound the tails
of this this privacy loss random
variable so we will take a leaf out of
kind of classical work on bounding tales
of random variables so if you ask a
progress how do you bound tales of
random variables the standard way is to
use moments so I have a positive random
variable the probability that it exceeds
epsilon is the same as probability e to
the Alpha times that random variable
exceeds e to the Alpha times axle
Epsilon I have just applied a monotone
function here and now I apply Markov's
inequality the probability that a
positive random variable exceeds some
quantity is at most its expectation
divided by that quantity and I have
introduced this alpha we will fix that
later as needed L this is true for any
alpha
okay so now we know that if you want to
bound this quantity it's enough to bound
this expectation
okay so let's compute this expectation
we are trying to bound it to the Alpha
times Z of X where X is recall drawn
from n 0 Sigma squared Z of X is just 2x
plus 1 over 2 Sigma squared the 1 over 2
Sigma squared is independent of X so it
just comes out and we are left with
computing this expectation when X is a
Gaussian
this is an easy exercise let's do it
this expectation is an integral of this
quantity the quantity we are taking the
expectation of times the density at X
there is a normalizing constant I have
written it down but you don't actually
need to know what it is
I usually don't remember okay so let's
expand this out I have an minus x
squared and a 2l for X let's try to
complete the square so this is x squared
minus 2l for X complete the square you
get X minus alpha squared over 2 Sigma
squared and to do that we had to add we
have to subtract alpha squared over 2
Sigma squared add that back this is an
equality why did we do this this law is
a constant independent of X this part is
the density of a Gaussian centered at
alpha is the integral of the so I'm
integrating the dense the density of a
Gaussian centered at alpha that adds up
that computes to 1 so I'm left with e to
the Alpha squared over 2 Sigma square
we still have our as the constant cancer
normalizing constant is exactly what
gives me one so that's why wait I
actually didn't even need to know it
good so let's plug that back in and we
get that the density is e to the Alpha
alpha plus 1 over 2 Sigma squared
let's plug that back into the tail bound
we were trying to compute we have this e
to the Alpha alpha plus 1 over 2 Sigma
squared as this expectation divided by e
to the Alpha Epsilon
and you get this funny expression to
keep the mat slightly simple i'll su
Malfoy's at least 1 so alpha plus 1 is
at most 2 alpha so I get this bound
okay so I have a difference of two terms
one is alpha times Epsilon the other is
alpha squared over Sigma squared I want
to make this smaller than Delta
I want this e to this whole expression
to be smaller than Delta and if the
simplest way to try to do that is to
make the negative term tool on Delta to
learn 1 over Delta and make the positive
term 1 times LAN 1 over Delta so let's
do that
I'll set alpha to be to LAN 1 over Delta
over Epsilon so that Alpha Epsilon is
exactly 2 LAN 1 over Delta and now I'll
set Sigma so that the first term becomes
1 times log 1 over Delta and you get LAN
1 over Delta minus 2 LAN 1 over Delta so
you get Delta here and now I can read
out what Sigma and showed that Sigma
squared here turns out to be something
like for LAN 1 over Delta our epsilon
squared which is basically what I
clipped so Sigma is 2 times square root
of 1 over Delta over FC
this is not the tightest pound you can
prove there are better bounds available
but this will be convenient and I guess
yeah I guess I wanted to show this
approach to proving things which is why
we proved a slightly weaker result than
we can prove but note that the only
property of this q function i used was
at QD + QD prime differ by at most one
so if you have some other function Q
that Maps data sets to real numbers that
satisfies this property that for any two
neighboring data sets the difference in
Q is at most 1 the same proof goes
through unchanged the largest difference
between the value of Q on two
neighbouring data sets is what we call
the global sensitivity of Q here I'm
saying that if the global sensitivity of
this function Q is at most one I can add
Gaussian noise and get differential
privacy
there's more I the same proof
essentially unchanged goes through if I
am trying to compute a vector function
rather than a scalar function so imagine
you have function Q that takes the data
sets and maps it to some K dimensional
vector and it has the property that the
two norm of the gap between you D and Q
D prime is at most one
then if I still add noise which is
partial to Sigma square I get epsilon
Delta differential privacy
the proof of this is essentially
identical I'm still measuring the
density I still want to talk about the
ratio of density about computing the
ratio of densities at two points when
I've moved the mean by a certain amount
from Q of T to Q of T Prime and note
that if I just draw the line joining
them if I rotate space so that the line
joining QD + QD Prime is my x-axis
gaussians can be written as a product
distribution over any rotation in all
the directions other than this one
direction the density function is
exactly the same in this one direction
I'm just using the one-dimensional
argument
questions
okay so let's think about this moment
for a little bit longer what we showed
was that for the Gaussian is nestled the
expectation of e to the Alpha times this
privacy loss random variable it's
something like e to the alpha squared
over 2 Sigma squared and if you think
about this this is a little strange at
first why is it straight so Sigma was
something like 1 over Epsilon so this
quantity is something like e to the
alpha squared epsilon squared
differential privacy says that the Z is
bounded by Epsilon so that's all I knew
about Z this quantity could be would be
e to the Alpha times Epsilon the scaling
in epsilon would be linear in the
exponent and I'm getting a quadratic
scaling in the exponent why is that
happening the reason that's happening is
that the privacy loss random variable is
a ratio of probabilities if the ratio of
probability is large at some X it has to
be small at some other X
so at a very so if you think of say the
Gaussian distribution if X is Sigma this
privacy loss random variable would be e
to the Alpha over Sigma but there's an
equal chance that X is actually minus
Sigma in which case this privacy loss
random variable is something like e to
the minus and power sit and if you
average these two out so let's do the
Taylor expansion of e to the Alpha over
Sigma e to the minus l4 over Sigma if
you if you have matching positive and
negative terms the alpha over Sigma term
will cancel and what you will be left
with is the second order
and this is not true this is not just
true for the Gaussian mechanism this is
a much more general statement if you
have any epsilon differentially private
mechanism then the expectation of e to
the Alpha times the privacy loss random
variable grows as e to the Alpha alpha
plus 1 times epsilon squared so even
though this privacy random variable is
only bounded by Epsilon the moments get
2 epsilon squared
you call epsilon is usually less than
once absalom squared is a lot smaller
okay so let's use this to prove a very
important property of differential
privacy which is composition so
composition says that if I have a
sequence of differentially private
mechanism m 1 through m k and suppose
each one of them satisfies a certain
differential privacy guarantee I'll call
it epsilon 0 D P I want to ask what is
the privacy of the full interaction what
can I say about this whole sequence of
interactions I'll call that M 1 through
K so I call that M 1 through K and I
want to ask what's the privacy loss
random variable corresponding to this
full sequence of questions
okay so let's write this down just by
definition this is log of this ratio of
probabilities now note that the
randomness used in the ayat mechanism is
independent of everything that happened
in the past so if I condition on the
previous outcomes mi of K has its own
internal randomness which is independent
of all past events so this probability
is can be replaced by a product of
probabilities
[Music]
yeah again I I'm not very sure about the
independence between each mechanism for
example let's say way
the mechanism is training a neural
network each time we need to use the
outcome of the previous so you're
absolutely right
I'm kind of lying here if I had to be
precise what I should really say is
conditioned on M 1 to I minus 1 being
equal to O 1 through I minus 1 and the
property we are using here is that even
conditioned on the previous outcomes I
may be running a different mechanism
that depends on the previous outcomes
but this ratio or whatever mechanism I
choose will be bounded because that
mechanism conditioned on the past is
still differentially private as you
serve what guys our assumption is that
maybe it wasn't obvious away you kind of
say every mechanism is absolutely
precious private know by what the
previous method isn't it yes perhaps you
can think of a choice function by an
adversary wherever or in the analyst the
chooses m'kay based on the PDS yes fix
any choice any choice the the output
mechanism is differentially part so the
choice of the analyst is always a
differentially privately and as
and I guess once we have these products
we kind of you log and product to get
some of logs and essentially what we are
deriving is that the privacy loss random
variable for the full sequence is the
sum of the privacy loss random variables
of individual mechanisms and I guess
here as we said this mi actually may
depend on previous outcomes but we'll
assume that no matter for every choice
of mi we have epsilon log differential
privacy so at this point we can easily
prove the what's called the basic
composition theorem in differential
privacy it says that if you have K
epsilon 0 differentially private
mechanisms their composition is K times
epsilon 0 differentially private why
because absolute zero differential
privacy says that this is bounded by
Epsilon I'm adding K of these so I get K
times Epsilon
and I guess this can be extended more
generally to epsilon-delta
differentially private mechanisms with
different values of epsilon I and Delta
I and if you work a little harder you
can show that this adaptive composition
satisfies summation alpha in summation
Delta I differential privacy
but we want to prove something stronger
this is a useful result but this is much
quicker than what is true so let's prove
the stronger result so let's go back to
our moments method we want to bound the
probability that Z M 1 through K elite
exceeds absolute so let's use again our
favorite Markov's inequality on the
exponential so we just need to estimate
X the expectation of e to the Alpha
times Z and 1 through K but recall that
Z M 1 through K is just the sum of ZM is
where again they are kind of
conditionally independent based on the
past and because they are independent I
am looking at the expectation of now
product of random variables which are
independent and in this case
expectations and product scope commute
and I get the product of the
expectations of individual e to the
Alpha times ears
each of these mechanisms satisfies
epsilon0 differential privacy so this
quantity is bounded by e to the Alpha
alpha plus 1 epsilon naught squared over
2 which is what we are earlier what we
argued earlier there's K of them so I
get a K here and if you just kind of
rewrite that you get something like this
and this should look interesting because
instead of epsilon nought times K I
haven't because I had a squared here
this looks like epsilon nought times
square root K squared
and I guess once again I can do the same
trick I have this dysfunction which is a
difference of two values let me set this
to be twice log 1 over Delta and take
parameters so that this becomes log 1
over Delta you do that and essentially
that ends up - setting epsilon being
epsilon naught times square root for
killin 1 over Delta so if I said
'absolutely to be epsilon naught times
square root 4 KL + 1 over Delta and then
choose the best alpha based on that this
probability can be shown to be bounded
by Delta which means I've shown epsilon
Delta differential privacy for this
value has
I'm making an assumption here is similar
to the previous case I have alpha alpha
plus 1 so to keep some things simpler
I'll assume alpha bigger than 1 but the
whole map can be done without making
that assumption and what you would get
is a slightly more nuanced statement it
says that the adaptive composition of a
differentially private mechanism
satisfies epsilon times something like K
Delta differential privacy where this
epsilon is epsilon times square would
kill on 1 over Delta type term that we
saw earlier plus another K times epsilon
naught squared
questions
good okay so we have done a fair bit of
basics of differential privacy let's
start doing some machine learning so
I'll start with kind of one of the basic
problems in an unsupervised machine
learning which is called principal
components analysis I guess I chose this
because this is kind of in this case the
mechanism is particularly simple and
easy to explain and actually has all the
nice properties that you would want from
a differentially private machine
learning algorithm
PCA problem I expect most of you have
heard of this but let me just set up the
framework here we are given a set of n
data points x1 through xn in some d
dimensional lattice V dimensional space
think of D being fairly large we will
assume that each of one of them is
normalized to have norm at most one and
my goal is to find a K dimensional
subspace which captures the most energy
of this vector so I want to maximize I
want to find a projection ok dimensional
projection matrix by K this is the norm
of the projection of X I to the subspace
and I want to find the subspace such
that in this subspace the total energy
is not just possible
if I write a as a matrix where each of
these excise the is a column matrix
then a classical fact in in linear
algebra is that this Maximizer is
defined by taking the top K eigen values
of a transpose so you look at the
covariance matrix of your data that's a
transpose you look at the top K eigen
value eigen vectors that should be eigen
vectors sorry
and if you look at the span of the
subspace span of those K eigenvectors
that's the subspace you are looking for
why do we want to do PC it's a very
useful subroutine for reducing the
dimensionality of data if you believe
that your data actually lies in some low
dimensional subspace which is your
signal and there are some added noise
which can be in full dimensional then
PCA would be a way to kind of get rid of
the noise dimensions and this is
actually a very it's a surprisingly
powerful algorithm not just in theory
but also in practice so for examples for
doing recommendations for the Netflix
challenge this algorithm is actually a
surprisingly strong benchmark you
believe that people's preference is
about movies lie in some low dimensional
subspace we can try to find the subspace
which find the pca subspace and just use
their project those projections to
predict movie preferences
so let's do private PC so now we want to
compute the subspace still but we want
to make sure that individual x i's get
their privacy so we'll think of two data
sets as neighboring if they differ in
one column or in one of the vectors so a
will be the matrix which has all n data
points a prime will have one of the
columns replaced by zero so I've removed
my data from the data set
okay so let's look at the covariance
matrix this kind of two possible
covariance matrices one for a and the
other for a prime the covariance matrix
a transpose is essentially just the sum
of X I X I transpose over the end people
in the data set so the difference
between the C I compute on a and the C I
compute on a prime is exactly X I times
X I transpose
so let me look at this matrix C - C
prime this is sort of my global
sensitivity the Frobenius norm of C - C
prime is just a Frobenius norm of xixi
transpose and it's not hard to see that
this Frobenius norm is just the square
of the 2 norm of X I so you can do that
that's kind of two steps so we would get
a factor of two for simplicity I'll just
assume I'm so I guess you can define
differential privacy with respect to
either changing my data or adding or
removing my data here I'm using the
removing my data definition
okay so what does this mean I have said
that the Frobenius norm of C and C prime
of C minus C prime is it post 1 which
means that if I take this matrix C
flatten it out into a big vector an n
square dimensional vector this big
vector now has l2 sensitivity at most 1
why because for windiest norm of a
matrix is nothing but the l2 norm of the
vector version of that matrix
so so now we should all know how to
solve this problem
C is a function of the data set which
has l2 sensitivity as a vector at most
one so the algorithm that you should
propose at this point is to take this
vector and then add Gaussian noise to it
for a covariance matrices are always
symmetric so we would like to preserve
that property but that just boils down
to saying that my vector that I care
about is just the top part of the matrix
so instead of a n by n matrix I just
need to output the these entries these
are they're fully determined so instead
of this being a n square dimensional
problem this is n times n plus 1 over 2
dimensional problem
so and I guess adding Gaussian noise to
this part corresponds to just computing
the noise matrix e where each with a
symmetric and each entry is Gaussian so
see twiddle is a quantity I can now
publish and now I can take my suited C
twiddle and do whatever I want to do
with it in particular I can compute the
top K sub space of C twiddle and output
that and because C is close to C twiddle
you would expect this subspace to be
close to the original to the actual
subspace and and we'll prove that but
first just to repeat this part of the
Meccan of the algorithm is just running
the Gaussian mechanism and we saw that
Gaussian mechanism for appropriately
chosen Sigma satisfies epsilon delta
differential privacy
so we have a differential private
mechanism when I set Sigma to be
something pretty small constant
independent of the dimension so let's
talk about the utility of this algorithm
we would want to say that this private
algorithm is actually a good algorithm
how are we measuring goodness we wanted
to maximize this quantity the total
energy captured by the subspace I outlet
so the natural question to ask is how
much energy is captured by the the
output of the algorithm I want to say I
want to lower bound this quantity
relative to the best possible value of
this quantity overall ranking
so now I'll use kind of the one of the
most useful tricks in linear algebra
which is to write the Frobenius norm as
a trace of the matrix matrix transpose
note that a transpose in the middle is
just my covariance matrix which I will
write as C plus e minus e why will i do
that that will become clear in the next
step the C plus e is just C twiddle and
this is a quantity that I will actually
know how to control and I'm left with
this term which only depends on
so so far everything is equality nothing
interesting going on now I'll use an
inequality which is where something
interesting happens
note that pike a twiddle is the best
subspace for C twiddle so it's better
than using pike aids
so I'm using the inequality that this
quantity is at least as large as the
same quantity with PI K instead of Phi K
twiddle and now I'll substitute back
that C twiddle SC + e I'll factor that
out this first term is now exactly the
optimal value that I was trying to match
what's left is two traces which look
like the projection of the error matrix
e - okay dimensional subspace
the nice thing about this is that this e
is a matrix that I chose and it does not
depend on the number of points in the
dataset it doesn't depend on a it's just
a random Gaussian matrix so now I can
bring in kind of it I guess one of the
powerful very powerful but relatively
standard by now tools from random matrix
theory which basically says that a
random matrix e essentially has all
eigen values roughly square root of T
I'm capturing some K of them because I'm
projecting down to K dimensions so it
follows that this trace by K e by K
transpose and similarly the other
direction is bounded by K times square
root of T
so that gives me a utility result that
the amount of energy I capture is at
least the optimal - a small additive
term K times square root D okay let me
say a few more things yeah rigor the
values you showed on the previous slide
sort of it works for all II because it's
a great question the first term can
actually be even better because these
two are independent the second term I am
using the fact that even the largest
eigen value of E is bounded by square
root D you are adversely picking some K
of them
good so this was the bound you get if
you don't assume anything about the
dataset if you assume as one often does
in statistics that there's a gap between
the K largest eigen values and the rest
you can actually strengthen this result
using results in matrix perturbation
theory and get even better buffs you
would be justified in asking why should
I have to pay this K square root D turns
out that you can show a lower bound so
using fingerprinting you can show that
so the results they were actually weaker
than the ones we have here I think the
matrices you get from the lower bound
construction are actually pretty
coherent or whatever pretty incoherent
so that would let you get around these
lower bounds if you make some gap
assumptions then you can definitely get
around this lower box yeah so if you
assume some spectral gap if you assume
that the best K dimensional subspace is
actually a lot better than any other
subspace then you can prove better box
this box can also so this isn't the
Frobenius norm you can you can translate
them to spectral norm as well yeah
square root of T yes
in essence you're applying the noise
after you found the optimal subspace
I know before we are adding noise to the
covariance matrix and then just running
your favorite algorithm to the
covariance matrix if we did the other
way around if we actually computed the
actual top K subspace and then added
noise to it we will do waivers but I
guess here you are outputting only the
subspace not the subspace time the
matrix yes you can't output the matrix
you just want to output the subspace
so that's actually a very important
point you could also have viewed this
problem as I'm computing a function of
my data set which is this projection I
could have tried to compute the
sensitivity of this whole function and
added noise to it that would have given
me significantly worse results so here
it was important that I cannot have
found this this intermediate object in
the algorithm which has very low
sensitivity and is very useful for
computing the optimum value and that
allowed me to get these very strong ones
the other nice thing about this
algorithm is that the runtime of the
algorithm is essentially the same as a
runtime of the non-private and when you
say you know you know easy covariance
that is the subspace that's not the
original yes so we publish so okay so
the algorithm can do one of two things I
can actually just publish C twiddle
which is the covariance plus noise and
let you do the top kick computation or
if I guess if I have more computational
resources than you do
I would actually compute by K twiddle
from C twiddle but from a privacy point
of view I'm essentially happy publishing
sequel
good and because I can actually publish
the covariance you can do other things
with this covariance you may have a
different key in mind than the one I
have you can compute your own key k
dimensional subspace you can also use
this for computing a linear regression
on the data set because you have the
covariance and that's all you need to do
linear regression and empirically Orr
has done a lot of work showing that this
works very well there is so I guess this
sort of is a nice algorithm because here
we were able to do many things we were
able to prove strong utility bounds for
the algorithm if you want to do
differentially private machine learning
we want to be able to say that the
privacy does not come at a large cost
and if you can quantify that that's very
appealing
you can try to phrase that as for any
statistic for any machine learning task
there's an inherent statistical error
that's present in that in the task
ideally we would want to be lower than
that statistical error in some cases we
will not be able to be lower than that
error and we would want to be I guess
ideally we want to prove lower bound
showing that what we are gate what this
algorithm is doing is close to the best
possible we would also like our
differentiy private machine learning
algorithms to be as computationally
efficient as a non private ones and we
will not always be able to achieve that
this was a happy coincidence where we
were essentially able to match the
computational complexity of the non
private algorithm and I guess some other
nice desiderata of private machine
learning algorithms would be the
algorithm should be simple easy to
understand having small constants turns
out to be important in practice as we
see in the next star and I guess it's
also useful if your algorithm is is
easily extendable often in machine
learning we have
other background knowledge or other
reasons to kind of tweak the problem or
the algorithm a little bit if your
algorithm can easily adapt to that
that's very useful let me spend just two
minutes on talking about convex
optimization so I guess a larger a large
class of machine learning algorithms
fall into this framework of optimizing
an empirical risk function so they look
like this you have some data set x1 to
xn and the goal is to find some
parameters i'll call them w that
minimize the average loss over data
points of some loss function between the
parameters and the W this is saying how
compatible this W is with this example
for example if I was trying to do
classification W would define a
classifier X I would be a labelled point
and this loss may be small when the
point is correctly classified by the
classifier and large otherwise in
traditional machine learning this loss
function is usually convex so let's
start with start there and we'll usually
restrict this W to come from some convex
constraint set when we do a
differentially private version of this
problem we will not compute W star but
we will compute some W which is an
approximation to W star and the kind of
approximation will be interested in is
how large is the gap between the law set
W star and the law set what your
algorithm outputs we call that the axis
risk
this is kind of a common paradigm as I
mentioned you can praise your
classification problems as a logistic
regression
you can also phrase linear regression in
this framework lasso support vector
machine
I guess often you are related you are
interested in a slightly different
version of this problem which is sort of
the population risk minimization version
and those can be related for this talk I
will just it will be convenient to just
think about the ERM problem so I just
state what's known for this problem this
problem is being heavily studied and we
kind of know what's possible I guess the
important result is this one which says
that if you have if you want absalom
Delta differential privacy the excess
risk looks like 1 over epsilon times
square root D over
and this is close to optimum if I didn't
care about privacy the bound here or at
least the population version of the
problem is like one over square root of
n so this is better in that there is a 1
over N dependence but worse that there
in that there is a dimension dependence
unfortunately that's unavoidable in the
most general case
there's lots of different algorithms
that work for this problem I've just
dated them here and this is my last
slide so let me just say a few words
about these
so
so as you can see three of these
algorithms I put the word Gaussian next
to them which is to say that they are
similar to the private PCA algorithm in
that we found the right step in the
algorithm to add Gaussian noise and that
is how I prove privacy so privacy was
proved was achieved by at taking a
non-private algorithm and adding
Gaussian noise at the correctly chosen
steps two of them use what's known as
the exponential mechanism which I guess
I will mention in the next star briefly
and one of them is actually a is a
strange beast it has its own privacy
analysis it doesn't fall into your
classical frameworks
yes so we will see an example of a
specific algorithm its analysis which is
actually and actually some real numbers
for for a specific application okay I
guess I am out of time so we can maybe
do a few more questions and otherwise if
you want to digest over lunch and bring
those questions to the next part of the
tutorial and then that also works ok so
let's let's stop for lunch let's thank
and all again so we resume into a
quarter and lunch is on your own